in this session i'd like to talk about
currencies why they matter and how to
bring them into analyses
whether it's financial or economic now
until about three or four decades ago
all you had to do was learn how to deal
with a domestic currency
so we were a u.s analyst he learned
about the us dollar
and to the extent that foreign
currencies mattered wasn't a big deal
for indian analysts you dealt primarily
are only in indian rupees
now with globalization we have to get
comfortable moving across currencies
because you should be able to value a
company in indian rupees us dollars
euros or japanese yen
so to understand currencies let's crack
the currency code
the key reason for differences across
currencies
is not country risk because that we can
deal with its inflation
currencies with higher inflation rates
will tend to have higher interest rates
and currencies with lower inflation
rates will tend to have lower interest
rates
now don't jump to any conclusions
because by itself you're saying higher
interest rates are bad they were lower
my value
not so fast to understand why currencies
matter
and ultimately should not let's take a
look at interest rates across currencies
in this graph you see government bond
rates in different
currencies in july of 2020. now
government bond rates
incorporate inflation but they also
include country risk
there are some countries when the
government issues a bond that interest
rate will reflect the risk in that
government
so here's what i've tried to do i've
taken each government bond rate and
taken out of it the portion that can be
attributed to government default risk
now this is an estimate that i've made
based on the rating for the government
and how much risk i see
but the red portion of the graph is
what's left
that is my risk-free rate in different
currencies
so let's start by stating what seems to
be an unassailable fact
risk-free rates vary across currencies
and the only reason or the key reason
they vary
is because of differences in inflation
higher inflation currencies will have
higher risk free rates
lower inflation currencies will have
lower risk free rates and currencies
with deflation
could have negative risk free rates
we'll come back and talk a lot more
about this in the context
of valuation and corporate finance but
that's something we need to get on the
table
now you'll notice there are only about
40 currencies listed on this graph
you're saying what about the other
currencies why aren't there risk free
rates in those currencies
the reason is very simple many
currencies
do not have a government bond
denominated in that currency
so you're saying how do i get a risk
free rate in that currency well
inflation is the key reason for
differences across currencies
there is a simple way in which you can
go from one currency to another and get
a risk-free rate in a currency even if
you cannot find a government bond rate
you just use the differential inflation
rate let me give you a very simple
example of how this would work
let's suppose you want to get a
risk-free rate in egyptian pounds
there were no 10-year government bond
rates denominated
in 10-year bonds denominated in egyptian
pounds
in december of 2015. so here's what i
did to get an egyptian pound
risk free rate i started with the us
dollar
risk free rate then i use the t-bond
rate as my estimate
let's say it's 2.27 to get a risk-free
rate in egyptian pounds
here are the two numbers i need to
estimate one is an expected inflation
rate in the u.s dollar let's say it's
one and a half percent
the other is an expected inflation rate
in egypt now all you might have is last
year's inflation for the moment let's go
with that let's say it's 9.7
i'm almost home free if i'm in a hurry
to get my risk-free rate in egyptian
pounds here's what i will do
i will take the us dollar risk free rate
2.27 percent
take the difference in inflation rates
which is 8.2
9.7 minus 1.5 and add the two numbers
together
that's going to be about 10.47 that's an
approximation
why an approximation because there's a
compounding effect that kicks in here
inflation builds on top of interest
rates if you want to be precise here's
how you bring it in you take one plus
the us dollar is credit that's 1.0227
and you multiply it by one plus the
inflation rate
in the in egyptian pounds 99.7 percent
1.097
divided by 1 plus the inflation rate in
u.s dollars
you get a risk-free rate in egyptian
pounds of 10.53
now remember the shortcut got you to
10.4 so you're in a hurry there's
nothing wrong with using a shortcut but
if you have the time
might as well do it right so that's why
interest rates vary across currencies
at this point you're probably puzzled
higher inflation currencies have higher
interest rates higher interest rates
should lower value right
well not really and here's why when you
do a project analysis you have to be
currency consistent what does that mean
if you decide to do your discount rate
in egyptian pounds
you get a high discount rate that cannot
be contested
but that same analysis should have your
cash flows in egyptian pounds
you think so what the same inflation
that gets
built into your discount rate will also
help you on your cash flows
high inflation currencies will have high
discount rates and much higher growth
rates
if you are currency consistent your
value or analysis of projects should be
currency invariant what does that mean
if your company is undervalued in u.s
dollars it should stay undervalued and
rupees we'll come back and address this
much more specifically later on
but remember when you pick a currency
you have to be consistent
all the way through now if you decide to
do your analysis in egyptian pounds
not only should your discount rate be in
pounds but your cash flows have to be in
pounds right
now to convert your cash flows into
pounds in future years you need expected
exchange rates
so let's talk about exchange rates if
you decide to be currency consistent you
often have to forecast exchange rates in
some currencies you may be
able to find a market based numbers and
others you might might have to forecast
your own
in fact i'm going to give you two parity
conditions you can use to forecast
exchange rates i didn't make these up
these have been around forever
one is called interest rate parity
that's built on the fact that
if you did not if you have interest
rates in two currencies exchange rates
for the future
are bound by those interest rates i'll
come back and talk more about this
the second is what's called purchasing
power parity we use differences in
inflation
put very broadly though there are three
ways in which you can forecast exchange
rates
one is you can hire an expert or be the
expert to forecast future rates based on
what your perceptions of a currency are
whether it's strong or weak and what do
you think will happen to the
fundamentals
the second is to trust market forecasts
forward rates future rates
the third is to use the parity
conditions interest rate parity and
purchasing power parity
let's talk about the pluses and minuses
of each
now if you hire an expert or you do your
own forecast
let's start with a reality check
exchange rate forecasting
is not very well done in fact like much
of macroeconomic forecasting
it barely beats random forecasts so to
begin with if you claim to be an
exchange rate forecast you have to have
something backing it up but even if you
believe
you're good at forecasting exchange
rates you have to be careful about
bringing in those forecasts
into your analyses so you're doing a
project analysis
let's say it's a brazilian project and
you have very strong views
on the brazilian indriya and you bring
in those strong views
into your forecast of exchange rates and
into your cash flows
you know what you have to worry about
your results will be muddy muddied by
the fact that what you find for the
project whether it's a good project or a
bad project
is as much a function of your views and
exchange rates as it is of your views on
the project
same thing can be said about valuation
if you value a company with your very
explicit forecast of exchange rates
your valuation is going to be a joint
product of both your views and exchange
rates and your views on the company
you might say so what let's say you're
really good at forecasting exchange
rates
why even valuing companies or taking
projects
there's a much easier way for you to
make money just go out
and play the exchange rate market so
if you're really good at forecasting
exchange rates why are you even doing
financial analysis and if you're not
very good
why muddy the waters so i'm very i'm
very skeptical about using expert a
personal forecast
the second choice is to use market
forecasts in the last few decades we've
seen
forward and futures markets develop on
many currencies
and if you're working with currencies
like the us dollar and euro you can get
forward rates for
one year out two years are 10 years up
what does that allow you to do
get a market estimate of what the
exchange rate will be 10 years from now
you say this is good
i'm going to argue there's a lot less
information than you think in those
forward markets but at least you have a
market set rate
now there are some currencies where
you're not going to get that lucky
many emerging market currencies there
might be forward markets but they won't
run 10 years out they might run a year
two years out
and in some currencies there will be no
market rates at all you have to
negotiate
a forward contract with a bank and the
bank will set the rates
but in some currencies their market
forecast might as well use them
but let's talk about what these forward
rates include
for instance these are the forward rates
for the us dollar
euro on on july 24th or 2020.
so you can see i can get one year two
years all the way out to ten years
so if i'm a company with a u.s company
with european cash flows or euro cash
flows
i can lock in the rate at which i can
convert these cash flows into the future
and if you have this and you have to
convert your us dollar cash flows into
euro cash flows or vice versa you can
use these forward trades
but let's now talk about the scenarios
where you don't have market set rates
well one condition that holds forward
rates together
is what's called interest rate parity
interest rate parity is an
arbitrage condition what does that mean
if you deviate from interest rate parity
you allow people to make riskless
profits and if you allow people to make
riskless profits they'll try and in the
process they'll drive the parity
condition
to hold if you have two currencies let's
say the dollar in the euro
and you have an exchange rate today
between the dollar and the euro
and you have interest rates on the
dollar in the euro
they're tied together the forward rate
is
actually not that informative it's not
an expected exchange rate it's tied
together by
interest rate parity so let's take an
example let's suppose
the current exchange rate is 1.1662
dollars
per euro let's say the inflation rate in
the us dollars is two percent
and the inflation i'm sorry the interest
rate in us dollars is two percent
and the interest rate in euros is one
percent
i'm all set i take 1.1662 today's
exchange
rate i use the us dollar interest rate
in the numerator and the euro interest
rate in the denominator
i get an expected exchange rate of 1.177
i expect the dollar to weaken against
europe because interest rates in the
dollar are higher
and think of why this has to hold for
arbitrage if interest rates in one
currency are higher than the interest
rates in another it looks
to you like it's easy money right just
go with the higher interest rates
what this parity condition means is if
you go with the currency with a higher
interest rate you have to accept
depreciation the currency
otherwise it will be a i mean this is in
fact the basis
for what's called the carry trade in
fact the carry trade is built on the
presumption that
interest rate parity might not hold so
what do people do they
borrow at a low rate let's say in the
yen has a lower rate than the us dollar
and they lend out of the us dollar and
they claim to make a riskless profit
if interest rate parity holds that
riskless profit will disappear
because those exchange rates will have
to move to reflect
differences in interest rates so even if
you don't have forward markets as long
as you have interest rates you can
use those interest rates to forecast
exchange rates in the future
of course for this to work you need one
year rates two year rates
three year rates in both currencies and
if you have those you can forecast out
rates
exchange rates even without a forward
market out there
which brings me to the final condition
you say what if there are no interest
rates that go into long term there are
many emerging market currencies
where you can't get one year rate two
year age three year rates in that
currency going forward
there's another condition that holds
that's not an arbitrage condition
it's a condition built on the
presumption that currencies eventually
have to buy the same basket of goods
that if you have high inflation in a
currency it will depreciate against a
low inflation currency
so let's assume you have two currencies
the us dollar and rupees
and you have a currency exchange rate
today between the dollar between the
rupee and the dollar
and i gave you the inflation rate in
that car
in in both currencies let's assume for
exchange rate is point zero one three
dollars per rupee and the inflation rate
is ten percent in india and one percent
in us dollars i'm picking very divergent
inflation rates for a good reason
so here's what i will expect to see
happen over the next year
if that one percent inflation rate and
10 inflation rate
one percent inflation rate in the us
dollar and 10 inflation rate in the
indian rupee continue
i would expect the rupee to depreciate
roughly nine percent next year that's
what you see
the expected exchange rate and if you
want to do it two years from now the
inflation rate is going to stay the same
for the next two years
just rate you do it again one extra year
now do you see why this is a very
convenient way to forecast
exchange rates because even if you don't
have interest rates you should be able
to make forecasts of inflation
and those forecasts of inflation hold i
can forecast out
exchange rates for the next year the
next five years so
you can go as far as you want as long as
you build under inflation assumption
in this table for instance i've taken
three currencies against the dollar the
indian rupee
the brazilian reai and the swiss franc
i've given the rupees six percent
inflation rate
the rei five percent inflation rate and
the swiss rank of point five percent
inflation rate
i'm going to assume a two percent
inflation rate in us dollars our
forecast start exchange rates
for the next year and for the next 10
years in each currency
notice what happens the indian rupee
depreciation so the indian rupee
in this case against a dollar because
the inflation rate and rupees is six
percent versus the two percent rate
depreciates roughly four percent year to
get more precise you have to use that
equation you saw in the previous page
roughly four percent year for the next
ten years the brazilian reality
depreciates about three percent year the
difference in inflation rates five minus
two
the swiss franc appreciates about one
and a half percent a year
purchasing power parity is built on
inflation
i'll tell you why i'm a believer in
purchasing power parity
to use purchasing power parity you need
inflation rates for the future using
what if i'm wrong
you know what it doesn't matter as long
as you're consistently wrong let me
explain
if you underestimate inflation in indian
rupee you're going to underestimate the
depreciation the currency
but you're also going to underestimate
the growth rate in indian rupees
it is one of those mistakes where
mistakes cancel out in valuation
analysis so even if you don't buy into
purchasing power parity it's good
to kind of think about what it tells you
about the future
i use purchasing power parity in much of
what i do in financial analysis you go
to see this in both my corporate finance
and valuation classes
but i hope this session has been useful
thank you very much for listening